you have for example the situation that
your opponent has still a lot of time
and you end up in time pressure that's
that's kind of a total nightmare tonight
and Magnus has played the move for B8
and and wow okay then Magnus Magnus will
be in for a very very difficult time
okay Rook p8 is his choice and he's not
making this move willingly ultimately
not trusting his calculation and I think
it is safe to say now Peter that Rook B8
was always the kind of emergency option
for Magnus and I think it's clear in the
context of how much time was spent that
he was calculating Bishop D7 I thought
that he would trust this calculation but
you know it we can't say for sure that
he didn't you know maybe he calculated
to that end game and felt that he wants
to preserve you know winning chances uh
with the Queens on the board I know it's
weird to talk about it yeah white is
currently better but here at least the
Queens are on the board and the position
is more undefined so a big big decision